I'm are the main character in the act of
killing was in fact the 41st perpetrator
I filmed and long before him I was long
before I met him I was proposing this
the method was not there for kind of
lure to get them to open up it was not
about giving them enough rope to hang
themselves indeed they had hung
themselves from the very first time I
filmed them it was a way of an it was a
response to their openness an effort to
try and understand why they're so open
and thus the mood as I moved up the
chain of command until I met Anwar I
wasn't looking for the right main
character rather I was exploring the
nature of this impunity and the whole
journey I took with Anwar was the turned
out to be the core of that exploration
what did you see in Anwar that you
didn't see in the 40 some others think
that Anwar Spain is somehow close to the
surface and I think through the
reenacting it became through on Mars
boasting it became clear something that
I think was true of everybody else which
is that the boasting is not a symptom of
the lack of remorse the lack of a
conscience but in fact the opposite is a
desperate attempt to convince oneself
that what one did was right it's a day
on Mars attempt to convince himself that
what he did was justified you know one
of there's another death squad in the
film named Adi and he says in the film
he says to Anwar killing is the word to
me killing is the worst thing you can do
but if you're paid well enough go ahead
and do it but the key to doing it
successfully is to make up an excuse so
that you can live with yourself
afterwards and I think all of the
perpetrators they killed they were
handed an excuse by the government
justifying what they've done and they've
clung to do your life for that excuse
and in Anwar perhaps because his pain is
so close to the surface he doesn't quite
believe the excuse and so he becomes
more and more strident in the
justification the justification spills
over into celebration perhaps with our
more in that celebration I thought I was
catching the essence
of a regime of impunity which I think I
was and that's how the film has been has
worked in Indonesia unmasking this whole
regime but I think also I started to see
that the paradox at the heart of all of
this which is that what appears to be a
sign of the lack of remorse is the
opposite actually it's a sign of one of
the conscience of the killer and and
beyond that in that paradox lies a
tragedy about how we as human beings
what how there's a downward spiral of
corruption and evil and that once you've
killed once you've justified you get
away with it you justify it you even
celebrate it it's actually because you
know it was wrong at some deep level
that you're celebrating it that demands
that you commit further evil it demands
that you having thus corrupted yourself
in that way it demands that you suppress
your sort of the survivors so they don't
challenge your version of the events it
demands that you blame them and then you
can shake them down in markets or steal
their land which you hear about and see
in the film and it demands that you kill
again because if the army tells you now
now till these people for the same
reason as you killed the first if you
refused the second time it's tantamount
to admitting that it was wrong the first
time and that's what these men have been
desperately trying to run away from
so in essentially you see the act of
killing documents witnesses the downward
spiral of corruption and evil that all
human beings are capable of because we
have morality
once we corrupt ourselves with an
original sin get away with it and build
a normality on the basis of the terror
in lies that live area
you